[Musique]
bienvenue une occupation leucate aude
interdit d'interdire
mais chez moi confinement oblige pour
une émission consacrée ce qui est d'ores
et déjà l'emblème de la période que nous
traversons actuellement l'emblème du
confinement il s'agit d'une oeuvre d'art
elle est installée en plein centre de
paris sur la place du palais royal
et quand on la voit comme vous l'avez
vous voyez actuellement on est frappé à
quel point elle nous parle exactement de
ce que nous connaissons aujourd'hui à
savoir que nous sommes enfermés chez
nous cadenassé chez nous elle s'intitule
d'ailleurs chez nous mais ce qui est
original c'est que cette oeuvre est
installé sur la place du palais royal
depuis le 12 mars
c'est à dire une semaine avant le
confinement alors je reçois aujourd'hui
pour l'occasion carmen mariscal bonjour
carmen vous êtes artiste plasticienne
vous êtes mexicaine mais vous vivez à
paris est-ce que vous avez conscience
d'avoir réalisé une oeuvre prémonitoire
non pas du tout c'était mais le thème de
confinement est un thème dans lequel je
travaille depuis très très long dans ça
m'a frappé aussi que que cette oeuvre
soient mises exactement on a une allure
est exactement le jour où on a commencé
annonçait qu'il ya qui allait avoir un
confinement et j'ai été frappé par sa
aussi alors il se trouve que je vous
avais reçu sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire avant l'installation de
cette oeuvre c'était au début du mois de
mars et vous nous aviez expliqué qu'il
s'agissait d'une oeuvre sur le
confinement amoureux chez nous elle
s'intitule chez nous et réalisé avec
des cadenas c'est donc une maison canada
sait mais avec des cadenas particulier
sont des cadres nice et cannes nat les
amoureux ferme sur les ponts de paris
oui c'est m bon c'est une maison ça
laisse là la pièce à la forme d'une
maison et c'est une structure que donc
que j'ai fait avec avec une équipe mais
c'est une structure qui prend c'est une
seule pièce qui prend plein de petites
histoires plein de petites pièces et
chaque chaque canard et le résumé d'une
histoire d'amour
alors elle s'appelle chez nous parce que
on on parle de chez nous comme une
maison mais chez nous aussi ça peut être
notre ville notre pays
l'autre nos toutous mais cette pièce est
cette caisse qui est qui a fait au
palais royal
elle l était pas conçu pour parler je
parle de confinement amoureux mais le
thème du confinement a toujours été
présente dans mon travail depuis très
très longtemps donc vous n'imaginiez pas
que l symboliserait à ce point le
confinement tel que nous le connaissons
maintenant aujourd'hui donc sur la
moitié de la planète quand on parle du
confinement on sait de quoi on parle on
parle d'une maison par là qu on est
enfermé et dont on n'a pas le droit de
sortir sauf à heure fixe
c'est exactement ce que raconte cette
oeuvre
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui dans paris
des heures c'est encore plus frappant
oui ça m'a dit moi je n'ai pas vu depuis
depuis le vernissage
mais les gens nous envoient des photos
ils me disent et ils m'envoient des
photos avec des canards qui passe à côté
ou dans une place tout tout vide elle
est là je trouve que oui qu'elle a une
force est différente elle est là de la
force
effectivement ce serait pas la première
fois que qu'une oeuvre d'art au fond
avait été pensé de telle façon par
l'artiste et ensuite à changer de thème
j'ai pensé aveyronnaise qui avait
pas une la dernière scène du christ et
puis il a eu des problèmes avec
l'inquisition il a dit mme non en fait
c'est pas la dernière scène c'est le
repas chez levi donc en fils a changé le
titre et ça change et 9 hrs on se
souvient aussi du spartacus de denis
fois y étiez il l'avait daté du 2
juillet 1830 donc la révolution et il a
été regardé j'ai fait l'écho des nikon
révolutionnaire sauf qu'en réalité il
l'avait fait pour le roi charles vi
trois ans auparavant et à l'époque qui
la lui avait vendu comme la statue d'un
d'un prince tomber en esclavage qui
avait levé une armée de mécontents il
s'était bien gardé lui dire de qui il
s'agissait
alors voilà peut-être que votre oeuvre
sur le profit des amoureux va devenir 5
tout simplement l'oeuvre du confinement
je ne sais pas ce qui est sûr c'est que
quand on crée quelque chose on la craie
après ça nous appartient pas du tout
après ça appartient à tout le monde qui
regarda presse appartient au temps où
elle était fait mais aussi au temps qui
passe à côté d'elle et puis et puis ça
appartient à chacun et à chacune pour la
lire de façon différents et ça dépend si
du de là où on est placé pour la pour la
lire et ça se trouve que cette pièce à
la platelle là en ce moment là alors
elle prend une autre lecture une sacrée
mais qui a à voir aussi voilà il ya elle
prend une sacrée ampleur
normalement elle n'était installé à cet
endroit jusqu'à la fin du mois d'avril
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles de la
mairie de paris est ce qu'elle va rester
j'espère bien on l'a on a demandé un
prolongement en attendant la réponse
mais de toute façon je trouve que ça va
être un peu même si on devait la
l'enlever de la semaine prochaine ça
serait un peu difficile dans le ton de
confinement et puis j'aimerais bien que
les gens puissent puisse la voir aussi
parce que presque personne n'a pas pu la
voir en vrai on va la voir lors en
images c'est déjà c'est déjà pas mal
mais on sait bien que en france on a la
manie des commémorations
on commémorera le confinement comme on
commémore les attentats comme on
commémore absolument tous les événements
dramatiques qui nous ayons pu nous
accabler dans l'histoire autant
commencer tout de suite et au lieu de
faire un appel d'offre et de demande et
descripteur de faire des oeuvres sur les
confinements autant prendre celle ci
qu'elle reste là est vitam aeternam
j'aimerais bien ça serait fantastique
ça vous dérangerait pas que tu aies coup
d'être d'être celle qui a fait l'oeuvre
emblème du confinement dans sa salle
beaucoup de lecture mais ça peut ça peut
parler de ça aussi mais comme il ya une
lecture de cette pièce que j'ai conçu
dès le début qui me préoccupe beaucoup
qui est la violence dans les foyers et
alors comme j'ai une pensée toujours
pour tous ces femmes il ya des hommes
aussi et des enfants qui sont victimes
des violences et parfois c'est des
personnes très très courageuse et puis
bon ça ça pourrait être aussi c'est
commémorer leur courage et pour tous les
gens qui travaillent aussi pour pour
faire ce qu'on filme en mieux pour tous
les trains les personnes qui travaillent
pour qu elle cette situation s'améliore
aussi bon moi je voudrais aussi les
combes et morel je ne sais pas si ça
c'est la meilleure façon mais mais il ya
beaucoup dé rossi maintenant merci quand
même mariscal portez vous bien et
j'espère que la mairie de paris nous
entendre avec eux et que cette oeuvre
restera là pour qu'on se souvienne tout
ce qui a eu un moment où on était
enfermé chez nous et justement elle
s'appelle chez lui ça me paraît donc
totalement approprié merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
au revoir car même merci au revoir
[Musique]
je